على كل ينضم الينا من جيزان الشاعر يحيى
رياني اهلا بك سيد يحيى معنا في صباح
العربيه اذا السعوديه تحتفي بالشعر العربي
وتسمى عام 2023 عاما له لم نتحدث اولا عن
القيمه المحوريه للشاعرنا وتاثيره في ثقه
في الثقافه العربيه
اهلا وسهلا وصباحكم صباحكم شعر
هذا العام او هذا
المبادره وهذا الاحتفاء بهذا العام العام
2023 ليكون عاما للشعر العربي هو اكبر
تاكيد على امتداد حضارتنا وتاريخنا
وهويتنا المرتبطه والضاربه في اعماق
التاريخ بالشعر العربي الشعر الذي الذي
ابتدا في في حقب قديما يعبر الانسان عما
في داخله ابتداء
كيف نبكي من ذكرى حبيب ومنزلي الى حبي
بصحنك فاصبحين الى الغادر الشعراء ترنمي
ومثيلتهم القصائد الخالده في جبين الدهر
يؤكد حرص القياده واهتمامها
بهذا الارث العظيم والموروث الكبير الذي
تضمه هذه الارض المباركه ومنها نشات
القصائد التي لا تزال
الشعر كلام عميق وكاتبه اعمق لكن هل مازال
للشعر العربي حيزا كبيرا وتقديرا للشعراء
في يومنا وعالمنا هذا
هي مساله جدليه هل لا زال الشعر حضور وهل
لا زال الشعر تقدير تكلم عن الشعر الفصيح
لا شك انه مر بمراحل متذبذبه في الماضي
وفي الحاضر يعني
يتعرض لعوامل كثيره ربما هي من اهمها ما
يتحدث عنه الاعلام وما يتحدث به
الاعلام لكن انا اتصور انها فتره ركود مرت
وعدت ولكن الان مع من الشعر العربي سيكون
حضور وتورج كبير لا شك سيكون الشعر
وللشاعر نظر الاهتمام القياده بهذه بهذه
اللغه العظيمه وبهذا بهذا الشعر الذي الذي
هو ديوان العرب كما قالوا الذي يسجل
تاريخه وماثرهما ذكرياتهم وانتصاراتهم
واسمائهم والهجاتهم ولغاتهم فهو ديوان
العرب كما قالوا ونحن نتفائل بهذا العام
بانه كما مر في في فتره ماضيه اقول ركود
ربما للشعر العربي ولحضوره على الاقل في
في مجال صغير النخبه لكن مع عام الشعر
العربي انا متفائل شخصيا انه
على الساحه حتى الرسميه طيب اهميه هكذا
مباراه سيتي يحيى لدعم الحاله الشعريه
العربيه وتعزيز حضورها في المجتمع بين
الشباب اليوم
ساهمت وسالتواصل الاجتماعي في وجهه نظري
نرى الان ونلمح من خلال حتى حتى الشباب او
البنات هذا يغني وهذا ينشد وهذا يقول شعرا
حتى لو لم يكن يعني يجيده خليني اقول
القاء ابوه او يجيد
نحو لكنه يحبه كثيرا ويطلب لسمعه وانا
سعيد جدا مجموعه من الاعمال الفنيه سواء
غنائيه سواء شاديه سواء القاء بدات في
الامر الاخيره ساهمت وسالته الاجتماعي في
تعزيزها بين الشباب حتى لو كانت محاولات
بسيطه وخجوله الا انها تؤكد ان الشاب
الشباب متلهف ومقبل على على ان يتبنى هذه
اللغه الشعريه عندما نتابع مراحل تطور
الشعر وخصوصا انه جاء من الجزيره العربيه
والشعراء القدامى اليوم يعني كنا نتحدث عن
كلمات ومصطلحات ثقيله وصعبه جدا هل اليوم
الاتجاه الشعري الى التحدث بالعاميه ومحبب
اكثر لقلوب الناس منه الى
ساقول كلام قد يغضب او قد يزعج بعض زملائي
من الشعراء ان المرحله الحاليه تحتاج من
فعلا اللغه العربيه لغه ثريه وهناك صعبه
لكن المفترض على شعراء الجيل والشعراء
نخاطبون الشباب ونخاطبون الناس عامه الناس
ان ينزلوا بالفاظهم ونختاروا من اللغه
العربيه
الانسب الالفاظ هناك في اللغه العربيه في
العين الف معنا وفي الاسد مئه معنا فلاذا
نختار الكلمات الصعبه وهناك متنفس كبير في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ان تقدم القالب
الشعري بابسط طريقه واسهل لفظ واسهل معنى
ليصل الى قلوب الناس متى ما تبنى الشعراء
هذا المنهج وانا اللغه العربيه لغه واسعه
وبامكانك ان تبسط الناس لا تنفرهم من
اللغه العربيه ومن الشعر العربي باختيار
ابسط افضل الالفاظ حين سنقول ان الشعر
العربي الفصيح قد وصل الى قلوب الشباب
طبعا لو نسمع منك شيء شاعر يحيى اقول اننا
نحن في عام الشعر العربي ومن هذه الارض
التي امتد منها المعلقات وتبدا منها الشعر
اقول انا السعوديه ذا اصلي وذي بلدي وصيه
لابي اوصي بها ولدي هذا جواز الذي في
العمر احمله من الوفاء كحمل الروح في جسدي
النوق والخيل مركوب ويجمل بي السيف الخنجر
الزاهي على عظم
انا السعودي كل الناس تعرفني في لهجه
ولباسي او بجود يدي انا السعودي والتاريخ
يشهد لي شيبت مجدا بغير العزم لم يشهد
الاربعون سروه والخيل مضمره مع الامام على
نور من الرشد تقدموا وظلام الليل محتلق
واذن الفجر والاعداء في بددي الملك لله ثم
الملك سار به عبد العزيز وهذه وثمه الاسد
انا السعودي راياتي وما نكست او استباح
احتلال الخبر في بلدي اذا رضيت نخيل الجهد
مسمره وان غضبت فلا ابقي على احد انا
السعودي داري سوف احرسها ولا اخاف سواه
الواحد الاحد
[موسيقى]
ويسلم هالكلمات الصادقه شكرا لك من جزان
الشاعر يحيى ريحاني شكرا لك